at the end of time
[Music]
13 o'clock
hey everybody what's going on it's
Wednesday night I think
am I in the shot yeah you're you're well
in the shot you're fine
you're fine it's Wednesday it's the
Regular Show we're starting at a little
bit of a later time because Jen uh Works
she comes home at five now and she's got
six six I didn't get home till six
because it takes me an hour to drive
from there
then I wanted to have time to have some
dinner and yeah go through my notes
again and all that other kind of stuff
yeah so it's just the way it's going to
be at least for now
yeah you know I mean I even printed out
the notes for the show and like took
them so I could read them on my lunch
hour but yeah
foreign
and I don't know like you know I I don't
know how long we'll be able to go on
because it's like I'll probably start
getting tired to worn out and stuff yeah
well yeah well the three hour show
action you know how it is
[Laughter]
they should only be two hours anyway max
if you ask me yeah probably yeah
um hey Jen how's the job got any boss
from Hell stories yet no I mean
everybody there is really nice I've
really only been there
like two or three days so it's not
really that big of a deal I mean
everybody's pretty quiet and
you know it's just I'm not you know it's
taken a while because I'm not really
like used to having to go
into like an office and do stuff and
the drive is kind of kicking my ass you
know what I mean so we'll see we'll see
how it goes
Ben says I've been working like a slave
all week getting books ready to sell at
the market this weekend in an hour I
have to go meet one of my friends who
has a van to bring some boxes here from
Storage well good luck with that uh like
I said you know we'll
um I don't I don't know like what time
is it now it's 7 30. so I don't yeah I
would really rather this not go past 9
30 because like I said I would really
like
to just
be able to like just take a shower and
relax and like watch a movie or
something for some reason
um this tablet is not running
um YouTube
I don't know what it is well I don't
know what to tell you
I didn't do it we have to get the other
tablet hold on one sec he's gonna have
to go get that other tablet Camp guy
said I like the later time makes me stay
up a little longer
normally I go to bed early like eight or
nine pm
I've been I don't think I've ever felt
well I don't know I think I've probably
fallen asleep at like 9 or 9 30 before
but
um usually I fall asleep by
10 30. but sometimes earlier like what
I've been doing lately because like I
said I've been getting up
really really early
like um to go because I have to leave
the house at like ten to seven like to
get there by eight o'clock just to like
make sure that I get there
Jesus Christ what are you doing working
what are you doing well I'm trying to
work too and you're making all this kind
of noise and it's like I don't it's
already like get in but the the volume
was off I already kind of distracted uh
and then Camp guy said I get up a lot in
the middle of night yeah I do too
I do too so I've been waking up at like
quarter to five and like not being able
to get back to sleep so just getting up
you know what I mean so just like I'll
kind of lay there and like look at the
clock for half an hour and then it's
like quarter past five and I'm just like
[__] it and then I just get up okay it's
working now
see everybody okay yeah I've got a
pretty good sized crowd everybody's here
that's good
yeah Zach said the weird thing is since
I've moved back into my parents place I
haven't been falling asleep till two or
three a.m and I've never dealt with that
this often before yeah I mean I've been
like
I'll put on like a like a show like on
Netflix or something like that and
usually I'll fall asleep like before one
episode has even gone like you know what
I mean
and last night it sucks because we were
supposed to do it um we were supposed to
talk about Gattaca last night but we're
gonna have to push that back to the
weekend because I got home and I was
just and I had this huge pile of like
freelance work that I had to do
um you know because I couldn't do it
while I was at work obviously so I had
to come home and do it and then it took
until like 10 30 at night and then I
just like fell asleep so
Trey says uh I got Sisters of Mercy
tickets I'm going to the Detroit show
yeah I heard they were touring I saw
somebody post about it earlier so I've
seen them a bunch of times
don't we did we see them together no
I haven't seen him in the modern era oh
I've seen them lots of times like I've
like I heard the [__] it's always a bad
show it's not bad
um it's but you know you can't really
see them but because you just smoke
everything out yeah but that's kind of
like well that's why we kind of laughed
at the um when we went and saw the cover
band yeah the Temple of Mercy because
they kind of did the same thing and I
was like I like that I was like you know
what I mean I thought that was a good
idea all right so today is a uh pre
Valentine's Day show that's going to be
about serial killer couples and we got
two of them yeah and I know how Jenny
does if she does more than one case the
[__] is going to be long this we're
going to be I tried to keep these short
first for real because well the thing
about it is that I was looking at our
past ones because we didn't do it every
Valentine's Day but like a lot of
Valentine's Day shows we did like killer
couple shows yeah and so we've covered a
lot of the big ticket ones like we've
done like Fred and rosemary West we've
done like Brady and hindley we've done I
think we did a show about Bonnie and
Clyde we did shows but so I'm kind of
like getting I don't want to say this
group in the bottom of the barrel but
I'm not sure if that's appropriate in
the situation but I'm getting to ones
that you know ones that we haven't
talked about because I kind of feel like
we've covered a lot of them you know I
mean like Ray and Faye Copeland and all
those kind of people like I know that we
did those on some other shows in the
past
so these two I don't think we've covered
them like I searched on our show and I
didn't see these two like one of the
stories sounded kind of familiar but I
think what might have happened was that
I might have had them slated to be on
one of the old shows and then we just
didn't get to it so because I'm pretty
sure you know it didn't look like we had
covered it previously so and I wanted to
do ones too where it was just because
there's one there was one that I was
thinking about doing that was like a
Russian
fam but it was a whole family though
it's like not just a couple it's like a
couple and they're grown kids who are
also serial killers like so they're just
like killing people left and right so I
wanted ones in particular that were kind
of like
couples that were serial killers you
know what I mean yeah so these are some
of the few that are like that are left
of like the ones because this is not you
know we've talked about this before it's
not a real common
it's not all that common you know what I
mean serial killers tend to be
uh you know lone wolves I guess it
happens though but it does happen and
like the Synergy of it is always like
really really strange I feel like
serial killer will recruit some
girlfriend who's a who's like a
satellite who [__] helps him and [__]
sometimes you know some of the surviving
victims say that the the girlfriend was
worse than the than the than the serial
killer too
uh like you know the West yeah isn't it
wasn't it the West couple yeah yeah that
cup that one girl that survived said
Rosemary was worse than he was
yeah it really kind of takes a special
kind of lady to um to end up in this
situation he said she said she was more
afraid of him
I said she said that she was more afraid
of her than she was him
no he was the one that did all the
killing
yeah that's I mean
these two are kind of similar in some
ways one of them is an American case and
one of them is a French case
um but yeah we'll get into that so Dave
is here I see I think that's who that is
is that you Dave big little I thought
that was like your name from before
slasher Fred said speaking of Bonnie and
Clyde one of these days you should watch
a review the 1967 classic we didn't we
didn't do the movie
we did a show about Bonnie and Clyde
yeah right like recently okay but we
didn't do the movie yeah what the [__]
was I thinking okay I must have like
been confused
about whether we did the movie or we did
the like did a thing about it Camp guy
said biggest single family Massacre was
in Arkansas dude killed 14 members of
his own family and two Neighbors in just
one incident I feel like I remember
hearing about that but I can't remember
exactly like what happened with that you
know what I mean
um all right so do we have anything he
said yeah it's me yeah I thought I
remembered that that was that that was
your screen name at some time
um do we have anything that we need to
uh address or get into or anything like
that no before we get into the actual no
we really actually should start the show
just in case just in case just in case I
fall asleep on the keyboard right yeah
let's just get this over with
well no I mean I want it to be a fun
show though it will be a fun show it's
just that we have to get we we have to
put this one on on a fast track yeah I
can't [__] around like we normally would
we can't but we can [__] around a little
bit but not [__] around in the show
let's just start the show and I'm and I
am drinking but this is like very this
week yeah it's one of those like Twisted
Tea things yeah just put it in because
it's much better when you put it on ice
just out of the can it's like not so
great yeah they weren't that great out
of the can
they're all right they're just kind of
like there's not actually a lot of
flavor too though I thought it'd be
better than I thought it'd be like a
Lipton tea you know like the Lipton
Brisk that's right like that it's not
like brisk but boozy yeah but it does
not what it tastes like no it doesn't
tastes more like beer and if you ask me
it does kind of it does a little bit
a big little said the [__] will be
slim to nothing tonight I doubt that we
always kind of say that and then like
you know [__] happens
but you know uh all right so the first
couple that I would like to talk about
these [__] uh Cynthia Kaufman
and James Gregory Marlow now here's
what's really interesting about this
Cynthia Kaufman actually has her own
Wikipedia page but her boyfriend does
not even though they killed people
together and I don't really get why I
guess because she's like one of the very
few women on death row like in
California maybe that's what it is so
maybe that's why she has her own thing
and he's just like just you're running
the middle [__] killer you know what
I mean
so
yeah and uh I don't know so okay so
let's get into this so Cynthia Kaufman
let's talk about her a little bit
so she actually apparently came from um
a pretty well-off family so it's not a
case of uh you know that she had like a
real shitty upbringing or anything like
that
um apparently her parents were quite
wealthy she grew up in St Louis and she
was born in 1962. now they were like
real real strict Catholics though so I
don't know if that tells you anything
now uh she seemed like she was a little
bit of a wild child uh from her teenage
years she actually got pregnant when she
was 17 years old
and because Catholics uh they were like
yeah well you can't get an abortion so
her parents made her marry the father of
the baby
and uh they stayed married for like five
years before she was like [__] this and
ran away from home essentially yeah what
country was this again this is no this
is U.S yes okay no the second one's
France but this one's just regular old
United States what year did you say it
was again
um well no well she was born in the 60s
but um the murders were mostly in the
80s okay murders were mostly in the 80s
so uh so yeah so she decided [__] it and
she just like lit out for the
territories pretty much uh she just took
her car and her clothes and that's it
now she's an ex-heard of in Arizona
and she's working at a diner
and she moves in with this guy that she
met
now um her and the boyfriend they lived
in a little bitty apartment and in 1985
they got evicted because they were
having like drunken parties all the time
so you know that's that's just what
happens
now in May of 1986
Cynthia and her then boyfriend I don't
know what his name was because he's like
incidental in this case
but they got pulled over for running a
stop sign
now when this was in Barstow
when the cops looked in uh her purse
they found a loaded Derringer and a
whole bunch of Meth
now even though I mean this is
California in the 80s but they
um they let her go
yeah I guess they're just kind of like
meth and a loaded gun all right you're
fine in the 80s math wasn't considered
anything serious really you know that
was the crack epidemic time they weren't
focusing on meth the Irish person didn't
even know what that was yeah that's true
you know what I mean [__] that'd be
like getting pulled over and they'd find
an ephedrine
you know and then in California you know
you could have guns in California
and you know derringers that's a two
shot over and under
little subcompact type pistol that goes
back to the 1800s that's traditional for
ladies pistol purse pistol they're not
gonna they're gonna do anything about
that it's my little purse yeah this is
my little purse myth yeah well the math
they didn't think that wasn't a big deal
of them and then neither was that little
pistol
yeah I mean yeah because I I remember
like not meth not being like a really
big thing until fairly recently yeah
until it became a problem yeah people
didn't know what that was
yeah murder Hornet said I didn't know
about meth until the 2000s yeah I don't
think I did either honestly like because
I remember like in the 70s and 80s
growing up like everything was
everything was coke you know everything
was cocaine and then heroin in the 90s
in the Army we would go up before a
field problem which is going out going
out to the field field trade and if in
the f300 first we'd go out to the local
local
um
uh liquor store and buy bottles of
ephedrine yeah because it'd keep you
awake right evidently that shit's
illegal as [__] now
an ephedrine because you can take it and
turn that into uh meth yeah there's a
with a pretty easy uh pretty simple
process it's like an ingredient to make
meth so I don't think I don't think you
can get it anymore Most states
but we were just
popping them things man to keep them
fall asleep at night
you know trying to stay away just things
things change you know
well yeah I think that's what well can't
you like make meth out of um like cold
medicine or something like that that's
why it's always like locked up at the
[__] store now yeah
like I think it's a main ingredient in
cold medicine yeah like they got a card
you like to buy the to buy the [__]
cold medicine I haven't bought any cold
minutes in a long time uh yeah Camp guy
said they keep it behind the pharmacist
counter
yeah what they had here in Florida this
was recently it was something called it
was called potpourri I think wouldn't it
yeah a little battle no not bad they
call it bath salts and then they called
it potpourri
and you could go to a local
liquor store and buy a little bag of
potpourri and if you were to smoke that
you'd get high as hell because the
Chinese laced it with all kinds of weird
synthetic drugs you just had to know it
was sold as potpourri
though
yeah it's just like potpourri you know
somehow they put it out on the they put
the word out through the underground
that if you smoke that potpourri it's
got
[__] at it it's the same thing with bath
salts it was they were sold as bath
salts but I guess you smoked it and you
got really high off of it sneaky and it
was that's how the Chinese were getting
stuff in here mango said I thought that
was an urban myth no I think it was bath
salts why that dude chewed that other
guy's face off see I thought that they
found out that he didn't have any drugs
in his system I haven't like I don't
remember it's like nothing came up but
it was probably because it was bath
salts they probably have a test for it
they probably don't know what's in those
bath salts well you think that something
weird would come up though if it was
making you high enough to like eat
someone else's face off
drugs can do [__] weird things and
they they were synthetic designer drugs
that didn't exist before so they weren't
illegal
yeah make something illegal they have to
identify the molecule or the compound
and they weren't doing that they would
just make a brand new compound and put
it in something like potpourri
and sell it and just tell the people who
sold it at the liquor store hey this is
a drug by the way if you smoke it you
get really high and that's it just oh it
sounds like crazy doesn't it yeah I
don't know they must be smoking it you
know I don't know how funny like the
person at the bodega or whatever this is
drugs by the way yeah I can imagine yeah
you go in there and you say this is a
pack it's a [__] potpourri what the
[__] is that
Chinese man I mean I figured that
anything like you go into any of those
kind of like convenience stores or
anything like drug convenience well like
anything that's on the counter yeah that
you're like why would they be selling
that on the counter yes because it's
drugs the one they used to have was a
little glass tube yeah and the glass
tube I think it had a couple little
corks one on either side and in the
middle was a little paper rose in there
and it was supposed to be cute as hell
and you go like oh give me that little
Rose it was like for a dollar that was a
crack pipe
what it was yeah put crack in it and
blow that [__] out put a crack and smoke
it through that [__] pot
that's pretty funny yeah yeah Camp guys
they're put in your bathroom so you have
a Christmas party
yeah that'd be a great [__] party
but yeah see we did get distracted we
did [__] around yeah we're talking about
talking about purse meth yeah
I do not have any meth in my purse not
that I know of anyway
um so yeah so what ends up happening she
has the purse meth and the purse pistol
but she gets released and the charges
were dropped right now her boyfriend
though he ended up uh getting like just
a six week stint in the county jail
now interestingly
because her boyfriend you know was in
jail and he went and she went to visit
him
she ended up meeting
his cellmate
who ended up being the other half of the
serial killer couple so yeah so it was
the cellmate
so that guy's name was James Gregory
Marlowe now he happened to be in the
jail at this point for stealing his
sixth wife's car
so Cynthia comes in
and uh sees him and apparently is
completely uh taken with his awesomeness
or whatever I don't know it apparently
it was kind of like love at first sight
or whatever
now this guy um he sounds like a real
charmer I I have to say now ever since
he was 10 years old uh he'd been a thief
uh and actually in 1980 he was sent to
Folsom Prison for a bunch of like home
invasions and like robberies that he'd
done at knife Point uh he actually got
three years for that and when he was in
prison uh he actually became known as
the Folsom wolf and he was also a
Neo-Nazi so great like he had all the
Aryan Brotherhood tattoos and all that
other kind of stuff so like I said he
sounds like a real winner
so um so yeah so Cynthia is at this Jail
visiting her other boyfriend and then
she sees like ooh who's your cellmate so
yeah the two of them like fell in love
and the boyfriend whose name we don't
know who and who was the one that
facilitated this whole thing uh she's
just like who I don't know who that is
so uh Marlo got out
it's like I said he was he wasn't in
there for that long and they uh started
going
um they left California like as a couple
now Marlo actually had some relatives
down south so they started kind of going
and hanging out with them and like
sponging off them all the time like it's
like hey can we crash at your house or
you know um and then sometimes when they
would do that they would then they would
like take [__] out of their purses and
steal money from them [__] like that and
then finally like the relatives would be
like well you just get the [__] out of
here please before you steal us out of
house and home so there was that
so uh so yeah so basically uh after all
of his relatives had basically said [__]
off you [__] sponges uh they ended up
being like homeless for a time they were
like sleeping in the woods and whatnot
now in July of 1986 uh the couple were
actually suspected of a burglary
in uh Kentucky
and they actually stole a bunch of cash
like a shotgun and like a bunch of
jewelry as well
and then they ran off to Tennessee and
got married isn't that romantic yeah
um and when they got married you're
gonna love this when they got married
Cynthia commemorated the occasion by
having a tattoo on her butt that said I
belong to the Folsom wolf
okay keep it classy Cynthia
I mean on her butt
uh yeah yeah she loves it that's
dedication man
well we'll see how that goes
I mean he probably told her to do that
yeah it's like a tattoo on your ass put
me on your ass
that yeah that totally that way that way
when you're cheating that dude could
look down and see who you belong to who
you really belong to see I think that's
what he brought me to money that's what
he was thinking probably
Ben says I think there was a true crime
book called property the Folsom wolf
well it might have been about these two
[__] so yeah
so yeah tattoo on the butt that's really
really nice
so so then after that uh they started
heading back out west again
now in October of 1986 there was a 32
year old woman named Sandra Neri
and she lived in uh Costa Mesa
California and she was going out this
evening to just get some cash out of an
ATM
and she disappeared
they found her car nearby but they did
not find her
two weeks after that October 24th 1986
they found her strangled body uh hikers
found her in Riverside County
the next victim was a 35 year old woman
named Pamela Simmons
she was actually reported missing from
Bullhead City Arizona rather on October
28th
now they found her car like abandoned
near the police headquarters there in
town and they thought just like the
first victim that she had been kidnapped
like while she was taking money out of
an ATM like by the curb
um and then 10 days after that on
November 7th a 20 year old woman Corona
Novus she also disappeared while she was
taking some money out of an ATM and that
was in Redlands California
um and this happened actually she was
like um getting money from an ATM like
in broad daylight it was like at a
shopping mall and she disappeared from
there
um the next victim was named Lionel
Murray
and she was 19. she was actually a
college student uh in psychology
and she was supposed to meet her
boyfriend after work but she didn't show
up
so he went to her work to check where
she had gone and found her car outside
she worked at like a dry cleaning shop
and uh the car was there but obviously
she was not there
the day after that they found her body
uh she was naked she had been strangled
they found her in a motel room in
Huntington Beach
she had also been raped
so I didn't know who rented the hotel
room well I don't I must been under a
fake uh an alias huh well we'll we'll
find that out we'll find that out like
in a little bit
so what ended up happening so this you
have to think this is like a very brief
span of time this is only like a few
months this is more like a spree I feel
like these two are on because spoiler
alert that's who it was it was these two
[__]
what ended up happening was that one of
the victims Corona Novus they found her
checkbook in a dumpster
and it was inside like somebody had
thrown at like gotten some fast food uh
in a bag and had put the checkbook in
there and like thrown it in the dumpster
and inside the fast food thing were um
it was either I can't remember if it was
like receipts or if it was like Motel
things that had Cynthia Kaufman and
James Marlow's names on them I wonder
how somebody found that somebody
dumpster diving
it's possibly I don't know and then you
find a checkbook in the garbage can and
you assume well this has something to do
with the murder
that's weird you know how do you find
something like that
well it could have been that he was
famous in the area or something maybe
and he's found it well that's what I'm
saying this girl got killed right
and I'm thinking maybe the dumpster
wasn't that far away from like where her
body was maybe maybe so maybe the cops
were searching it because that's I think
that's pretty standard operating
procedure is like to go through the
trash and stuff like that because you
never know
trash in the area right I mean you would
think but yeah so these two dumbasses
like there was paperwork with their name
on it like in a fast food bag that had
this dead woman's checkbook in it
dumbasses well you know they didn't seem
like the brightest bulbs kind of tell
you
um and also
this like I said these two are not not
really all that bright so around the
same time that they found this bag
uh they also were uh connected to this
other motel room in San Bernardino
now the manager like after I guess after
they checked out or whatever but they he
went in there and you know how there's
like Motel stationery
so they had been practicing signing the
name of Lionel Murray like one of the
women that was killed yeah they were
practicing signing her name
so and they had checked into the hotel
under their real names because like you
know the manager said yeah here's their
[__] like you know what I mean so the
cops were like uh okay so they knew who
they were looking for then and then they
like checked the criminal record and all
that other kind of stuff so they put out
like a Statewide you know APB for these
two idiots go ahead and hit that like
button people yeah everybody
super chats are active and so so is
super thanks if you guys want to put
something in the uh in the tip jar if
you're listening to this recorded and
the super tanks goes for all the way
back in the past all the old videos that
we did now you can put a super thanks on
them I think they I think they should
all have that they should all have that
I mean I didn't go back and look at all
of them but they technically there's
yeah so right now they got people
listening to those old videos they
didn't hear me say that and never will
oh
and blowing up
well I mean you have to like think about
that because I get comments on like
really old videos like all the time yeah
and I get like comments from people it's
like oh I just found your channel you
know what I mean like listen to some old
ass video most of the Channel's income
doesn't have to do with the new shows
it's all the old shows added up
pretty yeah pretty much that's where all
the uh
ad revenues coming from
because they yeah they do build up like
after a while like because we've done
something footprint we've done so many I
mean what this is episode what did I say
it was 338 well that doesn't count like
all the movie reviews well I think Super
chats end up being more than uh being
more than uh ad Revenue doesn't it
um I it's hard to tell because they just
lump it all together okay they just give
you one lump sum like once a month you
know what I mean like that's that's
everything and they've also started
giving ad revenue for shorts now too
okay so I might have to like start
putting some shorts up but
when I have time which I don't right but
you know what I mean not until not until
all this [__] evens out yeah once I get
everything figured out like I said it's
like I feel bad that we didn't do as
many movie reviews but we might have to
cut the movie reviews back to just doing
one on Sunday yeah because then that way
like gotta pay bills have more time yeah
like I can do this because if I know
what the topic is then like I said I can
do all the notes over the weekend and
then read them like on my lunch hour and
it's like prepare I won't be able to
like watch a bunch of documentaries and
stuff like I used to but right because I
don't won't have that much time to keep
the show going no you got to get a job
so we can pay bills well yeah I know so
I gotta like work it out somehow right
you know what I mean yeah we're figuring
it out but like I said this is the first
week that I started so it's like I'm
still
she's still adjusting I'm still
adjusting to the new schedule like
trying to figure out like the best way
of doing [__] and that's not the work
hours just getting her it's the [__]
two hours of wasted time during the
commute right that's yeah that kind of
sucks I mean when I get
um that's the thing like when I get like
my phone because as it is now because my
direction my sense of direction is
really really bad so I still have to
have the GPS on when I go back and forth
otherwise I'll forget where I'm going
because I've only been there like a few
times so once I don't need that anymore
then I can maybe like run some podcasts
like through my phone so I could
actually like listen to podcasts about
topics that we're doing like while I'm
so at least I'm not feeling like I'm
wasting all that time right you know
what I mean so that's kind of what I'm
doing but like I said I still have to
have the GPS on right now and I have to
like listen to her because otherwise
I'll get distracted and like forget
where I'm at
but when it's a good thing today because
today for some reason I was coming home
and the lady on the GPS was like hey we
found you a route that's four minutes
faster and I was like uh okay this one I
don't know what the [__] I think they
were doing road work like up the road
and they just she steered me around
yeah yeah yeah
Mega said it will all come together yeah
I know it's just it's stressful like
when I because I had like a you know
system and everything and now
everything's like disrupted and
you know what I mean like it'll be good
to have money and stuff but everything's
gonna be [__] kind of catches catch
can for a little while until I get
everything figured out but we'll get it
all figured out at some point
um so yeah
um where was I okay so uh so they are
looking for these stupid people right so
they put out like a Statewide alert
now uh these people on November 14th
1986 uh the cops were called by a
manager uh at a like a Mountain Lodge
resort type of thing in Big Bear City in
California and said hey those two
[__] are looking for uh they're
staying here
so like I said they're probably using
their real names like they don't really
seem like they were trying to hide or
nothing like that
so they call like the [__] Cavalry
out there man like a hundred cops go out
there to try and catch them
um but by the time they got there they
uh the people had like am sprayed you
know what I mean they weren't like in
there anymore
so they
swept out into the woods like looking
for them and it took them a couple hours
but they did actually find him they just
found him like walking along the side of
the road they had run from the hotel
because they knew the cops were coming
but they found them just like walking on
the street later on so they got arrested
and uh they didn't put up a fight or
anything like that they just let allowed
themselves to be taken into custody both
of them were wearing clothes
that they had stolen from the dry
cleaning shop where they had kidnapped
kidnapped one of their victims Lionel
Murray so you know again keep it classy
and also uh after they were taken into
custody they didn't really try to they
seemed like they didn't really try to
deny anything you know what I mean like
as soon as they got caught Cynthia was
like a couple hours later she's like uh
oh yeah we know like we'll show you
where the bodies are
so she took the cops out to like um
Fontana like there's like a Vineyard out
there and they found Corona novus's body
like she'd also been strangled and she'd
also been sodomized they put her in a
great in a like a little shallow grave
so she was just like oh there she is so
you know
so the two of them get charged with that
that one murder like on November 17th
and then you know get held over for
trial right
and they uh they said really these two
they really didn't seem like they were
trying to get away with anything because
they said that fingerprints both of
their fingerprints were found inside
that woman's car
and also Cynthia Kaufman had gone to a
pawn shop and had hocked the victim's
typewriter and like used her real name
and everything like that so you know
like I said they weren't really the
brightest I don't know anything about
investigative Tech probably good because
it would have taken a long time to catch
them I mean it's sad that like there's
so many people had to get killed but
it's like holy [__]
so um so yeah so they were actually in
jail
for uh
uh almost three years like before they
went to trial
and in that time period they actually
um broke up
so uh they kind of turned on each other
which I guess is not all that surprising
like each one saying it's like oh he did
it no she did it you know what I mean it
was that type of thing
um and here's a Funny Story one uh
Cynthia's lawyer like went to see her
and said oh is there anything you need
like from outside or anything she said
yeah I want somebody to remove this
tattoo from my ass
which I was like that's funny nope
you're stuck with that stupid ass yeah
I was like yeah how'd that work out for
you good good job good job
so uh the trial was in San Bernardino in
1989 and uh both of them were just got
convicted of everything
um and they both got the death penalty
so Cynthia Kaufman was actually the
first woman sentenced to death in
California since capital punishment was
restored there in 1977 and then she went
on trial again in 1992 for another
murder and then she got like another
life sentence like on top of that now
the thing about it was that it seemed
like Marlo was just like yeah I did that
[__] like he didn't really care about it
Cynthia admitted that she did it but she
said that she suffered from battered
woman syndrome that Marlo had like
forced her to do this stuff and
I don't know like it's possible but they
normally strangled him right yeah yeah
yeah and they and they were generally
raped as well so what was she doing she
was watching that happen I guess yeah I
mean it seemed like that so I don't
really know
I don't know I I kind of feel like maybe
she was a willing participant and then
until she got caught because I didn't
have anything to do it and then she was
like she didn't have anything to do with
it I don't know it just it seems like I
know it's really unusual we've talked
about this before like on a lot of our
killer couple shows but it's very
unusual
uh you know obviously for a woman to be
a serial killer that's that's quite rare
um and there really has to be like an
interesting dynamic between the couple
for this to happen and a lot of times
I don't know a lot of times you do say
yeah the woman's worse but I think a lot
of times I'm always kind of gonna say
like 95 of the time I think if that
woman hadn't met that particular man
like she would not be have been a serial
killer on her own you know what I mean
it has to be like some kind of synergy
thank you thank you Bryce Google banned
me again just like last time for trying
to pay from another device I'm bad with
pins and passwords yeah but now it's
good love the show thank you very much
thank you very much Bryce very very
appreciated yeah no they do exist the
little serial killer satellites they had
one
you might remember their names just a
long time ago I remember reading a book
and they were in it
uh it was in a true crime books a long
time ago
kind of this big fat Mountain Man type
he was big into guns and
he had a girlfriend and she was like
she's actually pretty good looking
especially for him you know
and he'd drive around in a van and
abduct
teenage girls
and they were both having sex with them
and the woman was having sex with these
like 16 17 15 16 year old girls also
and then they drive them to a remote
location and she'd hold a gun on them
and make them dig their own Graves
remember that one I think she shoot him
and [__] then they'd cover them up
that was a he looked kind of like he was
on his flannel shirt wearing big like
big old Duck Dynasty looking yeah yeah
it looked like some [__] hillbilly
type
big old beard and well somebody
mentioned earlier the toy box killer was
that who it was because his girlfriend
did help him on a couple of things
Toy Box yeah which one was that well see
I think it's confusing because I'm
pretty sure that they were Toy Box yeah
that there were a couple that were
called uh
but didn't yeah it wasn't the toy box
killer I want to say I don't know that
you're the toolbox I don't know I don't
remember the name of that one
of the one that I'm talking
you look like a cow remember Cal from
[__] Sanford his son
[Laughter]
his girlfriend they look like they were
dressed up like they want her to look
like Hillbillies
like almost like a costume like
hillbilly cosplay yeah it's like
hillbilly cosplay Ben said he was
wearing a Canadian tuxedo yeah
you know
uh is it was it the Elephant Butte
torturer
I don't know that one I don't know
what's an elephant if you torturer never
heard of that one but you don't you
don't know what those three words mean
separately or together not even together
nor separately
no torturer is a beaut
is [__] medicine in it now I thought
a Butte isn't it like a um kind of like
a flat top Mountain type of situation
it's like a landscape feature okay no I
don't know a beaut that's what that is
somebody can correct me if I'm weird
honestly we don't have any Buttes all
right but I'm pretty sure it was like
aspirin that you gave a horse
give him some Butte that's what we used
to do
well I'm sure that's probably short for
something okay didn't it I don't know I
mean I would imagine it was horse
aspirin of course that's pretty yeah
I thought you were gonna say something
else
yeah Camp guy said uh Toy Box is David
something toolbox is Bittinger bidinger
and Roy Norris yeah yeah those toy boxes
David Ray Parker yeah that's right
uh and then it said it was in the town
of Truth or Dare
they changed the name afterwards the
name was originally from a game show
competition in the 50s oh okay
I was oh I was thinking of that other
Town that's called Truth or Consequences
I didn't remember that there was one
called Truth or dead it's a little
weird-ass [__] town names in this
[__] place but yeah so uh Cynthia is
uh apparently still alive she is still
on death row just sitting there uh in
the central California women's facility
and uh still saying that she
that she was forced to do the murders I
don't I don't know if I believe it
though
but you know what I mean like I said I'm
not saying that doesn't happen because
I'm sure it does but I don't know I kind
of feel like she was maybe into it I
don't really know well that's what I'm
saying about that one that was
holding the shotgun on the girls and
making them dig their own Graves and
then blow them away and [__] covering
them up she was definitely having sex
with them but then she didn't go to jail
because she uh cut a deal to testify
against him
and she claimed that she was uh forced
into doing it she was scared of him
but I believe so I don't believe so I'm
sure she was scared of him yeah but she
had all kinds of opportunities to like
run
you know and go to the [__] police
and get rid of the dude but she didn't
you know
Ben said yeah the toy box killer David
Parker Ray lived on Elephant Butte in an
RV
gotta watch them people live in an
elephant mute
why would you name a town Elephant Butte
I don't know or a Butte Elephant Butte
does it look like an elephant
it's shaped like an elephant I don't
know
okay so we're going into the second case
yeah see I told you they weren't that
long no it's the perfect length
she thinks that's short that was a whole
show right there okay let's do another
one
we haven't even been that was at least a
half hour we haven't even been going out
we're only at four we're only at 48
minutes yeah that that's a whole show
yeah no Super Show most people shows are
an hour Jenny you're giving away too
much free [__] man
okay giving away too much free [__] well
I mean it's all the live streams I just
like I kind of have a good time so you
know what I mean
why are you shaking your head at me for
imagine you got a girl out there on the
corner she's trying to [__] bring you
some money you know what I mean and
she's out there giving away free [__]
you're like no make them pay
you know that's you
just giving away fresh
no it's an hour hour isn't it most most
people's shows are an hour
yeah okay I know okay well we'll just
you want to do three or four hour shows
especially when you've been drinking
well yeah well I can't no you say you
don't have enough time
and then you say well we're not making
any money off the show
because they're sick of us making too
much material
flooded the market where all material
yeah maybe you're right yeah maybe
you're right they're trying to get rid
of us
[Laughter]
would you guys just go away yeah
we're probably not going anywhere I mean
like I said we do have we will have to
like do fewer videos and stuff just
because we don't have time to do them
but it'll be better
I mean I would hope so people will
actually show up listen to the [__]
yeah it'll it'll don't worry about it
it'll be all right
but you know I do I worry about
everything I can't help it I just that's
what that's you gotta be like me you
gotta be like a psycho where you don't
worry about it but I'm not a psycho I
don't really care personally okay it's
gonna be okay everything works out
well all right everything works out
I know it's just everything's like just
like I said it's been being appeaved and
I'm just kind of like not used to it we
finished this show right here and then
you get you some sleep and then we'll
worry about tomorrow and then it'll
it'll all come together yeah well I
don't want to come together I don't want
to go right to sleep after the shower I
want to at least have a chance to like
just lay down and watch some stupid
Channel little Debbies eat me some
little Debbies A Little Debbie unicorn
cake you know what I the unicorn cake is
pretty good but I was surprised that the
one that's the good is like the Cherry
Moon Pie thing yeah Cherry moon pie is
good I mean is it called a moon pie no
it was called a Valentine's cherry
cordial I think is what it was called
okay but I didn't think a moon pie I
didn't think I was gonna like those but
actually those are quite delicious it's
it's a it's a chocolate moon pie with a
slight maraschino cherry flavor to it
just like you you're eating a little
maraschino cherry with The Cordial it's
like that they're good yeah it's a
Valentine's Day
it's Valentine's Day flavor from Little
Debbie flavor yeah
yeah I wasn't crazy about the unicorn
cakes where me and my sister were
watching uh a YouTube channel she likes
it's called gut check and they did a
whole uh show about Little Debbie's and
they were like trying all the different
flavors like to see which ones are the
best and I think the unicorn cakes are
like their least favorite unicorn cake
it's like a little
it's like a little dildo with [__]
[__] rainbow color Brony [__]
graphics on it so it's like that's what
the Universe I can't figure like what
flavor is it supposed it's gay flavored
it's gay gay flavored gay brownie flavor
strawberry strawberry strawberry cake
with with what with
vanilla fondant
and then vanilla cream
with [__] rainbow drizzle
unicorn drizzle on it it's like some
and it's all sexual
I I it didn't occur to me that it was
sexual that must be yeah that must be a
you thing it says unicorn on it man it's
all LGBT
yeah
it's shaped like a dildo it's not shaped
like a dildo it's Square it was like
rectangular it's rectangular
no
if it was shaped like a dildo I just
suck something about it it's like yeah
it's like a bar like it's just like yeah
that's not a dildo shaped okay do you
don't have a square dick no a
rectangular dick I've never seen anybody
with a rectangular
you don't know what you're talking let
me tell stories
spinning and narrative okay okay if you
say so just tell stories all right this
unicorn flavored it's unicorn flavored
yeah yeah it's gay flavor
yeah
like I said I'm pretty sure it's
strawberry but and everybody wants to
see it
[Laughter]
see you're over selling it you're over
selling the dildo yeah okay I'm gonna
eat a unicorn cake
okay don't don't shoot with your mouth
open
don't give me us I'll have one later
though
but yeah I don't know what he's talking
about it's not until there's not until
they're shaped at all
I don't know other than the fact that
it's long that's about it it's not like
a [__]
okay he's bringing it he's bringing it
yeah
yeah see it's just it's a rectangular
okay this is even got a strawberry on it
yeah I didn't realize so you just got
the little [__] rainbow [__]
drizzle unicorn drizzling on it
um
now we're just gonna sit here and watch
you no go ahead go on with the show all
right go on with the show all right so
let's talk about these two other
[__] all right please be French
[__]
now this guy I feel like this guy is
probably like more famous now and he
this guy he killed some people like on
his own but then like he got her
involved too like what do you don't drop
girls all over my desk
strawberry cake
yeah Zach says that's the gayest thing
I've ever seen and that is me talking
Jack this [__]
it's gay cake
[Laughter]
with a Y at the middle
it's pretty good I like this you'd like
it Zack
[Laughter]
but see nothing like a dildo I don't
know what you're talking about I'm just
making sure up yeah I know that's what
you do
that's what you do
so uh so yeah so let's talk about this
[__] so this guy this guy is
named Michelle fornare Foreigner Ray let
me say
what it's probably Fournier but there's
more near Ray
f-o-o-r-n-r
foreign
no it's not foreign
but like I said I'm not gonna pronounce
it I took French for four years but I'm
not pronouncing it French because I was
only good news Okay
um so yeah so this guy is actually he
actually has a serial killer nickname he
is known as the ogre of the Arden
now he actually uh also had a fairly
normal upbringing I think
um he you know was kind of working class
they said he was very very intelligent
uh as a kid very quiet and he was really
into classical music and chess and stuff
like that it's kind of like you know
nerd but
no no shade against shade against nerds
um now he later claimed that his mother
had sexually abused him I don't know if
that's true or not but that's what he
said which might have
um maybe explained like why he got into
the [__] that he got into later on you
know what I mean thank you again Bryce
gotta go but we'll listen to the rest
later love the show keep up the good
work thank you very much that I really
do appreciate that very much that's
awesome yeah usually listen to it
tomorrow
listen to it tomorrow
uh so yeah so I don't know if his mom
actually abused him or not but
usually I don't know these dudes would
end up being serial killers they usually
have real complicated uh relationships
with their mother sometimes their dad
too but you know what I mean so I don't
know
even though he always uh he seemed quite
intelligent according to everyone that
knew him as a child they said when he
grew up he couldn't really um hold the
job which you know kind of common for
this type of person and you know so he
would just like he was a forestry worker
for a while like he just he just did
kind of like menial jobs you know what I
mean
also it seemed like he started out on
his criminal career a little bit early
uh he was actually arrested for the
first time in 1966 uh for sexually
assaulting a young girl and this uh was
the first time but would not be the last
sadly
now by the time that this happened that
he was arrested for this and he was put
in prison and at that point he was
married for to his second wife so he'd
actually found several people to marry
him uh in spite of being the absolute
worst so I I don't know who the [__]
I don't know who the [__] is you know
having sex with this dude but okay
so his second wife uh takes off like
while he's in prison
so he's lonely so he puts an ad in a
Catholic magazine looking for a pen pal
which I guess a lot of prisoners do and
there's you know prisoner groupies
and uh this woman here was one of them
her name was Monique Olivier uh she uh
already had two kids
and she answered his ad in the Catholic
magazine hey the other the last one was
Catholic too thank you very much Bryce
sure sure that's just a coincidence
did you you did yeah yeah yeah you've
been gone yeah
I already I already got it yeah
so yeah so she starts corresponding with
this [__] while he's in prison
and they apparently exchange hundreds
and hundreds of letters
and in the letters before he even gets
out so there's really no excuse It's
like oh I didn't know what he was like
or anything like that because before he
even gets out he's writing in letters to
her that he has fantasies of raping and
murdering virgins damn which uh you know
you think if you'd read that you'd be
like well I'm not going to write to this
guy anymore that's a giant red flag
right there but no she's just she's just
like yeah okay
is she like oh yeah she went she went
one better than that yeah she said tell
you what I'll help you do that when you
get out if you kill my ex-husband okay
cool cool all right I see this sounds
familiar I know this case yeah this one
is like slightly more famous than the
other one like I said I think that we
were either I don't think we've talked
about this one before but I think that I
had it in my notes before and we just
didn't get around to it like on one of
the other shows I mean if we did do it
before then
I didn't put it in the [__] uh tags
because it doesn't [__] yeah uh Ben
said doesn't anyone check these letters
that's kind of what I was wondering
Maybe not maybe even maybe in France
back then they did it
you know what I mean because usually I
would think like over here don't they
open them yeah I don't know if they read
them
they probably pretend to read them
they might read certain important
inmates most of it's probably really
boring most is boring probably
they probably focus in on a couple of
people
some kind of Investigation smuggling in
drugs that kind of thing or if it's you
know I would just think that that's
probably targeted because yeah a lot of
times it seems like it would probably
just be a waste because a lot of times
it would just be like your mom right and
be like are you wearing clean underwear
in prison you know what I mean exactly
so uh so yeah
so she says yeah I'll help you I'll help
you rape and kill Merchants if you kill
my ex-husband he's like sure can do he
never did do that though but they killed
lots of other people so you know but he
never got around and [__] he never
gotta ever got a ride
because he's like yeah it's not really
my bag but you can help me do my [__]
yeah that says typical dude right it's
like you help me do all my [__] but I'm
not gonna have fun yeah I'm not gonna
help you do your [__] yeah that's pretty
much so he gets let out of prison
in 1987 uh and they you know started a
little relationship there
and uh soon after that him and uh
Olivier started their their uh project
let's call it that let's go the BT case
this is France this is well yeah they it
was France and they did a bunch in
Belgium too like they were kind of going
around everywhere
so okay December 11th 1987. so the two
of them
are driving to
um a town whose name I can't pronounce
and they drove in separate cars
and this is something that they would do
like I said it was very like Brady and
hindley where they because a lot of
times like a serial killer if he has
like a cop like a female accomplice
um you know it helps because you know
people are obviously not as wary of like
a couple or a woman as they would be a
man you know
understandably so but yeah they use that
to their advantage
so they're both in separate cars now
they see this 17 year old girl Isabel uh
La Vie now they had actually been kind
of stalking her like they'd been
watching her like for a day or two like
that she was like walking around she was
walking home from school
so um so Olivier Monique she stops and
asks
um this girl hey can you um come get in
the car with me and like give me
directions how old is she 17. no no the
uh what's the name Olivia what's her
name Monique yeah what's her name how
old is she um I'm not sure actually I'm
not sure actually probably 20s or 30s I
would think yeah I mean this was back in
the 80s you know what I mean
so so yeah so she's like I need some
directions can you like come get in the
car and like show me where I'm going so
the girl was just like you know she's
it's just a woman so she's like fine
so they both get in the car and she
starts driving down the road and then
Monique gets to the spot where Michelle
the you know the her boyfriend was
standing with his car and he was
pretending that the car had broken down
so that was kind of like their whole
plot here
so Monique like stops the car and it's
like hey person whose car broke down
um you know why don't you get in I'll
give you a ride to a garage or whatever
so uh then at that point Michelle gets
into the car
and uh then choked uh the Girl Isabelle
with a piece of rope and then gave her
Rohypnol
uh Monique gave her a hypnol and then
they took the girl to their house
and Michelle raped and strangled her
and then they threw the body down a well
uh her remains were not found for 18
years now did she regain Consciousness I
don't nobody knows I don't know
I mean yeah I don't know
I mean it's I hope not but
that's [__] up
[__] up
so yeah that was their little project
there
March 1988 so Michelle gets a call
from a 30 year old woman named farida
Hamish
now this woman was the wife of a guy
that um that Michelle had shared a cell
with
so this guy whose name was Jean-Pierre a
name last name I can't pronounce was a
bank robber
so the two of them had been in a Cell
now the wife calls him up and says hey
can you help me like go dig up this big
like um
Fortune essentially that they had they
had like hidden it like in this Cemetery
somewhere there was they were all
members of this gang and they had stolen
all of this money like it was a lot of
money like a [__] ton and they had
stashed it in the cemetery
so she calls Michelle and says hey can
you like help us come and dig all of
this up and we'll give you some of it
so they go there and it's like and it's
like a [__] pirate treasure band it's
like gold ingots and like gold coins and
all kind of [__] like that it's [__]
crazy like pirate treasure
so they go there and they get it all out
so then uh the wife like farida hamesh
she gives Michelle
um like a share of it that's worth like
500 000 francs like for helping you take
up like I said it was a [__] ton of
money
and then like she uh hid the rest of it
in her apartment
which um this probably wasn't the
brightest idea to let like [__]
Michelle on in on this stuff because uh
and we'll see why in a second
but yeah then he goes there and steals
his [__] and kills her uh yeah that's
pretty much exactly what happened yeah
so yeah not too long after that like a
couple months later
um he's like
uh Michelle and Monique
they took uh they took for Rita out to
her house they're like hey come with us
and like do some [__] I don't know what
they told her exactly but they drove her
out to this kind of remote area and then
they strangled her and buried her and
then they went back to her apartment and
broke in and took all the [__] money
and then like you do they use the money
because it was a lot to buy like
essentially a castle it was like a
castle it was like on 32 Acres or
something like that like it was this big
Chateau so I was like okay I mean we
wanted a place to live living the dream
yes
everybody's like killing the people so
right it was gold a lot of it was I
don't know what else it was but I know
it was like a lot of gold and if there
was like there wasn't a connection to
her they could have got they probably
got away with it we'll see how it goes
but if you had
if there wasn't any solid connection to
the victim
they just show it with the money they'd
probably get away with it probably yeah
because I'm not entirely sure like where
because Michelle was not part as far as
I could determine he was not actually a
part of the gang like he wasn't like in
the gang that had stolen the money you
know what I mean he was just like he was
the cellmate of one of the guys that had
stolen the money
and like the wife was like you know so
now they got their murder torture castle
out on the 35 Acres pretty much yeah
that's yeah
he thinks he's [__] Dracula I guess
so yeah I mean if you've seen him he
doesn't look anything like Dracula but
it's like he just looks kind of he looks
kind of like a I don't know like a dork
beta he's beta pretty much
um so yeah now by August of that year
which was 1987.
um Monique
was pregnant with Michelle's baby so
great another one yeah they're making
another they're making another one
so while she's uh so while she's
pregnant even they the two of them go to
like a grocery store
and they find a 20 year old woman named
Fabian Leroy in the parking lot
Monique pretended that she was sick
um I guess because she was she was
visibly pregnant I think at this point
so she was like oh I'm having a problem
with my baby or something like that
so they cut they go up to this girl and
they're just like hey can you like come
over here and like give us directions to
like a doctor's office
and so the girl gets in their car
and then they drove to this Forest like
near this military camp or something
like that
and then at this point Michelle this is
so weird and like I said this is kind of
tying back to what I was saying about
him like claiming that his mother abused
like sexually abused him I don't know if
she did or not but it's like this might
have some he has like a virginity fetish
or like a thing about virginity and it
might have something to do with them
being raised Catholic too I'm not really
sure or inadequate well maybe he could
he can in his mind impress The Virgins
maybe that's what it is yeah because he
never running whenever you run into
usually when you run into the [__]
virgin fetish it's inexperienced guys or
inadequate kind of guys who are worried
about their own impressiveness or their
performance so if it's the woman's first
time she has nothing to judge him
against so in his mind she's impressed
you know what I mean
but it you know [__] [__] when I was
a kid
then you hook up with virgins on a
regular basis when you're a kid at least
when I was a kid
that's the last girl you want to sleep
with
virgins are terrible
well everybody it's not a good
experience you know it's not a good
experience everybody got to start
somewhere you just pop it and jump off
and go and get you next week reel up
you're so gross enough
well you feel sorry for him you know
do you really
how magnanimous of you
it's evidently horrible
it's a um it it depends I guess it's
different for everybody all right but
you know what I mean it is yeah it's
usually is no I had two of them I had
two it was [__] horrible it usually
is quite painful yeah not always but
sometimes
like I've I've heard you both uh try to
get it over with and then just
next week we'll do it again
but you just you just pop it
it's so gross though yeah yeah
he knows that's how we did it Ian
England said virgins are awkward as [__]
yeah yeah I mean like I said it's
understandable it's like you know I tell
you to do it then you're trying to stop
at the same time
you gonna knock them out come on just
come on you can do this okay go ahead
[Laughter]
kill the hit never mind well it's the
legs over here okay that's it okay so
it's over with it's over with
I'll be back in a second
yeah
[Laughter]
how do we get into this
how do we get into this conversation gay
unicorn dildo cakes yeah popping exact
shows all about him he [__] agreed he
goes that cake is gay as [__] so I know
well I mean me and Zach are having a gay
experience together over the goddamn
internet with the cake okay now you can
now you know Zach's gonna go out and
look for the Little Debbie [__] gay
unicorn cakes they're pretty good
they're not as good as the other ones
yeah the other ones are better I mean
they're pretty and everything but
I'll tell you they're probably not the
best the Little Debbie chocolate chip
cookies the two chocolate chip cookies
with the cream with the with the
marshmallow cream filling in the middle
those are good the two oatmeal cookies
with the marshmallow for those well I
think this is two snickerdoodles is the
best style they're good too yeah I
haven't liked the snickerdoodles better
than the oatmeal pie I she said that
there's a peanut butter one but we
haven't found them I'm looking for yeah
the peanut butter one and it's big it's
not it's not the same size as those
because those are like small it almost
looked like a [__] Burger yeah like I
couldn't figure out because I just saw
it like on a YouTube channel and I
couldn't figure out like what the
outside of it was made of yeah Nutty
Buddies are good it's like a big wafer
cracker with chocolate peanut butter and
those are good thank you Jack Torrance
Jack Torrance is in here it's good [__]
right what'd he saying oh [__] he gave
he gave us five dollars you didn't say
anything okay thank you he just popped
in like here's Johnny again okay yeah
that's what he should have said you
should have said yeah it's too late now
but you know what I mean uh so yeah so
where was I okay so
so they pick up this girl in this
parking lot of like a grocery store
because she's like Monique is pretending
to be sick and so they take this girl to
this Forest
and then Michelle tells Monique like his
girlfriend hey why don't you look at
that girl's hymen to see if she's still
a virgin
and Monique's like no I'm not doing that
and then
um so Michelle was like well I guess it
doesn't matter then and then he'd raped
her and then shot her in the chest damn
so
yeah that was the thing like he would
always like ask him if they were
versions and stuff like
something like that so yeah and and here
here's another case where that happened
January 1989 dude's a [__] loser yeah
well if you'd see him like [__] I get
a hold of him ask him if he's a virgin
he's like no I anniversary says you
can't be a virgin
you gonna be a virgin bro
you have to drill him a new hole come on
Cheers
you could be digesting billions of my
children here in a few minutes man
he and England said LMAO these
conversations are the best I know it's
like I never know how this happens I
never everything just gets away from me
you know what I mean and it's like it's
I thought like because he's I feel like
he's kind of taken advantage a little
bit because I'm like really tired and
I'm kind of like but I'm taking
advantage
[Laughter]
I guess I'm just kind of like it's like
I'm so sleepy and it's like I didn't
really get like uh yeah I didn't get a
lot of time to
prepare for the show and stuff
all right so January 1989.
Michelle meets this uh 21 year old woman
named genre me uh Jean-Marie
does oh [__] does remote
[__] I can't remember how it would like
pronounce that
so he actually met her on a train
and the two of them just had like
seemingly a normal ass conversation
and it turned out that uh the girl was
staying at a Convent which I'm sure like
perked Michelle's interest because he's
like oh Convent maybe she's one of those
virgins that I've
um been looking for for all my life
so
um at this point like Monique and uh
Michelle they had actually like made up
false names like they were presenting to
be other people
and they came back to the train station
again like a day or two later and then
they started like talking because I
guess she took the um you know
Jean-Marie she took the train all the
time so they came and like started
hanging out like befriended her type of
thing
so they're like hey why don't you come
to our house and like have dinner with
us or something and I mean she kind of
knew them because she'd seen them and
stuff she was like okay and
um you know Michelle's like oh well you
know it's fine I'll drive you home
afterward it'll it'll be fine
so they get to their house and guess
what the first thing that Michelle did
was ask if she was a virgin which seems
like a little bit of an inappropriate
question but you know what I mean
um now she said I guess much to his
Chagrin
that no she had a boyfriend so she
wasn't a virgin
and uh that made him really really mad
so he basically like attacked her
so she um you know tried to rape her and
she fought back against him like and
tried to get away but they essentially
the two of them like overpowered her and
gagged her with um like adhesive
bandages and then Michelle strangled her
and then they took her body and buried
it in a garden like uh a few like of
their uh Chateau or whatever
Michelle and Monique got married in July
of 1989. how romantic I think I said
that this is [__] before they
got married so these two got married
also because
man you just you know when you find your
person because it's like the person's
just they they like to they enjoy doing
things together I guess like like
killing virgins so it's pretty [__] up
so on uh December 20th of 1989. they
actually drove across the border into uh
Belgium I believe they went into Belgium
and at this point they had a kid because
their kid had been born so their son was
one year old
now you might think that even serial
killers would balk at using their kid as
bait to learn victims but in this case
you would be wrong because they
absolutely did do that damn
um yeah
now at this point Michelle sees a 12
year old girl Elizabeth bruchet
she was walking to her friend's house
and he basically like kind of followed
her and then waited outside for her
until she like came back out of her
friend's house to like walk back home
again
and then he pulls the trick he pulls
over and he's like hey um can you I you
know I have my kid with me and he's
really sick like can we um you know do
you know we're a doctor's office is
so she agreed to get in the car and show
him where the doctor was so she got it
so they took this girl back to their
house
and basically they stripped her and then
saw that she was on her period And so
Monique had to go and like clean her up
now the next day
they took the girl to their Chateau they
kept overnight or whatever yeah
and then Michelle tried to suffocate her
with a plastic bag but it didn't work
and so then he strangled her this is
after he raped her yeah okay so he did
raber yeah
and then
um they buried her in the chateau's
garden as well like near the other near
John Marie the girl they met on the
train
now
um interestingly well they didn't know
where she was for a long time and I
think that after
she went missing like there were
actually a lot of reported sightings of
her but I think when they I mean
eventually when they found the body they
were like oh well I guess those were all
[__] but that that kind of happens a
lot like when people go missing but the
thing about it I was watching like a
little bit of a documentary about this
case beforehand and the even it wasn't
that long but he was kind of going into
what a [__]
um the whole investigation was because
not only were these two [__] like
killing people in two countries it was
like France and Belgium and they were
and this was kind of like the 80s so
they didn't really communicate with one
another to any great degree but they
think maybe that there was a lot of
young women
that we're going missing or getting
murdered or something like that and they
the cops really didn't they either
didn't really seem to give a [__] or
they just like say oh they're just
runaways something like that like they
just didn't really investigate it to
anybody so a lot of the parents of these
victims were like really
um not not pleased with like you have to
have leads
you know what I mean
to investigate you have to have a lead
right so just because you have parents
go out and she's gone
they're like okay yeah she's gone where
do we start
you know
there's nowhere to start the
investigation he's just gone yeah
so I understand
you know the position the cops are in
because yeah we know she's gone we just
don't know where she is
no leads
well yeah and the thing about it too I
guess and this happened uh probably more
like back in the 80s and stuff like that
before they even have the internet and
all that kind of stuff is that
there were so many runaways and there
were so many you know people going
missing and stuff that they just didn't
have the manpower to like deal with it I
guess and if you were someone that was
you know I hate to say it but if you
were someone that was involved in a
high-risk lifestyle like you were a sex
worker or a drug addict or something
like that
I'm not saying they wouldn't look for
you but they probably it probably
wouldn't be like super high priority in
general investigation starts when they
find the body that's when the
investigation start
well yeah because like like yeah I mean
there's too many people missing persons
cases there's millions of them yeah yeah
and you don't know most of them are
alive and some of those people yeah
might have just taken off you know
willingly especially if they're adults
so a lot of them are never reported
missing
yeah that happens too yeah they'll find
them they'll find somebody dead and then
be decade be a decade before they
identify them and then it [__]
was never reported missing
you know what's crazy is that ever like
since I've been putting um posts up on
my uh crime immemorial blog and you know
taking stuff from my books and like
updating stuff you would be amazed I
mean they're kicking ass like
identifying victims nowadays that have
been like unidentified for decades and
decades because I'll go in there
um and it's like oh here's this case of
like whatever this Jane Doe was like
from 1979 or something like that and I
go in there to see if there's updates
and a lot of them have been identified
yeah like they haven't solved a lot of
their murders but they know who they are
now yeah um you know because they're
like well we didn't know who this girl
was for like 30 years they just found
her on the side of a road someplace yeah
and nobody knew like nobody identified
or nothing like that but they've been
identifying a lot of those victims the
ones that tend not to be reported
missing are middle-aged men and and
older because those guys [__] skip
town all the time low income middle-aged
man
well yeah but well there's nothing to
have any content they don't have any
[__] ties with anybody and when they
when no when you don't see them and they
just don't show up anymore nobody thinks
anything
well it's not horribly suspicious yes
like when a grown man that's kind of a
Drifter that doesn't really have family
when they because they're like oh maybe
they just got a job somewhere else and
decided to move or something like that
like obviously it's a lot more
suspicious when it's like a teenage girl
not saying they don't run away from home
but it's like that it's much more likely
that they're going to come to a bad end
yeah you know what I mean whereas like a
dude might just move to another town and
yeah get a job on an oil rig or
something I don't know yeah they've
[__] found weird [__] we're finding
middle-aged man dead in his car at the
bottom of a lake he's been down there
for [__] 20 years nobody even knew
where he went
[__] funny we ran off the road you
know that kind of thing that happens a
lot it happens a lot well you know did
they um how recent was this I remember
hearing about it I think it was fairly
recently but a guy I think it was a guy
that had gone missing like a while back
and they didn't know where he was and
somebody some astute person saw on
Google Earth like some like somebody had
take you know they had taken a picture
um of this Lake and you could very
clearly see like kind of a car like you
couldn't be able to see it like from the
the shadow of the level yeah but it's
like from up above like you could see it
and it was pretty plain that it was a
car down there and like so they reported
they're like hey is that a car like
might want to check that out and uh so
they went and checked it out and that
guy that was missing was in there
and you've been in there for like years
and years yeah but it's like yeah they
found it on Google Earth I have to look
up I don't remember like what year it
was from but I remember that being like
kind of a big deal which is crazy
um
manga said is their kid still alive not
to jump the gun I'm not actually not
sure
can you imagine like if these were your
[__] parents Jesus Christ that's like
[__] hard you want to change your
name
well yeah I mean that seemed like that
the first order of business wouldn't it
because Jesus Christ
but yeah so um okay so now the last
known murder that Michelle uh fornare
committed with uh Monique Olivier
actually happened on November 21st 1990
and this was uh in France like near the
west coast of France
so they drove to like a shopping center
type place and
um because they actually had they had a
court date for like not for murder but
for burglary like in some other place
and they like just drove to this place
it's like you know you get out of court
for robbing people it's like hey let's
go pick up a victim and murder them that
seems like good thinking you know what I
mean
so they go to this shopping mall and
they see this 13 year old girl named
Natasha Danny and she was walking
through a parking lot like she um I
guess she her mom had like left a purse
somewhere and she was like going back to
get it or something
so these two [__]
um lured her into the van again asking
her for directions
and they stuffed her in the van they
took her to kind of like a isolated area
and then stabbed this girl this is a 13
year old girl
twice in the chest with a screwdriver
and then strangled her and left her body
on the beach
oh and Michelle also raped her after she
was dead damn so yeah
classy
yeah these two I mean it's so gross
now
um about a week after this like another
like somebody that was a member of the
little girl's family
he actually got arrested because some
people had reported hey we saw her get
into a white van and he happened to have
a white van
so he got days like oh maybe it was a
family member and [__] like that
um so but obviously a spoiler alert he
wasn't the one that did it uh but he was
in jail for it while they were trying to
figure that out uh for two months and he
committed suicide so there's that
um even though like I said he did he
didn't do it no they he just happened to
have the same van as these [__] he
had like the the murderer Raper van yeah
the child molester van I guess he didn't
couldn't take the incarceration or
people were accusing him because yeah he
basically said he didn't want to be like
thought of as a murderer even because he
hadn't done it you know what I mean like
he could just couldn't take the
accusation it's like he just killed
himself yeah I had to wait a couple
months well you know that's easy to say
but it's like when it seems like your
whole [__] world's crashing down on
you yeah you know that's pretty shitty
so at this point uh Michelle Monique and
their kid which is crazy
um they moved to Belgium how old is the
kid at this point baby right yeah I mean
he's he was a few years old okay
um they moved there in the early 1990s
now Michelle after he got caught he
actually said that he committed two more
murders in France like without Monique I
guess like she knew about it but I guess
she wasn't like directly involved
so
um because apparently there was like a a
gap of like nine years where they didn't
commit any but then he just couldn't
resist so he had to go do some more so
he said that between 2000 and 2001 that
he actually drove um across the border
like into Belgium
in May of 2000 and Lord an 18 year old
girl named saline Sazon she was walking
home from school
um and he lured her into his van
and drove uh her to and then drove her
to Belgium and then raped her and
strangled her with a rope and dumped her
body in a forest
uh they actually found her body uh it
was a skeleton when they found it in
July of 2000. then in May of 2001 uh
Michelle drove back to his hometown and
kidnapped a girl who was 13 her her name
was
Anya thumpong she was um Thai
and he had actually given her a ride
home a week or two earlier but obviously
hadn't killed her so she didn't have any
reason to like distrust him right I
think he was kind of doing that kind of
situation
so um so the second time he picks her up
he's like hey why don't you come to my
house and play with my kid you know what
I mean because he had the Sun at that
point which you know he he really did
have that so she gets in to the van
and uh he drove her to like some remote
place and strangled her they found her
remains in March of 2002 and she had
been almost entirely eaten by wild
animals 13 year old girl Jesus Christ
so dude needs to die in a [__] in a
pitiful way yeah in a very painful yeah
very very painful you take your time
with that one
yeah I think you might need to like just
peel his skin off very very slowly put
him in a very small box in a very
uncomfortable position for a long time
just break his soul
yeah yeah
break his soul first then his body
so Michelle actually ended up getting
arrested at his house in Belgium uh on
June 26 2003 after he attempted to
kidnap a 13 year old girl and she jumped
out the car and ran to the cops and I
identified that's what I said hero yeah
so yeah she was like [__] this [__] she
just like jumped out of ran at like
mostly just [__] go like Lambs to the
slaughter [__] a lot of them don't
victim blame because a lot of them are
like little kids they're a little kid
like that but but no even adult women
don't do that sometimes too to jump out
the goddamn car
it was like well that's what they always
tell you don't ever ever ever let
anybody take you to a second location
don't ever let anybody take it and
here's another one uh the two teenage
girls they let the teenage guy in the
back and then he goes uh keep driving I
got a gun on you
you bring that car up to about [__]
70 or 80 miles an hour slam the [__]
brakes on as hard as you can and turn
the wheel to the right or the left the
hard as you can roll that damn car all
right injure and or kill everyone in
that goddamn car because you have a
chance of coming out of there live doing
that all right and he has a chance of
dying
but that's the same as calling for help
he's not going to be in any [__]
condition to do it he raping or murder
it you know after after you roll that
car at about 80. all right don't [__]
drive your don't drive your murderer to
a [__]
crime scene you know where you're the
victim [__] stupid run the car into a
[__] wall
put it into a [__] skid bam
sideways bam you know I mean you you've
got a weapon in your hands if you're
driving
you know
make everyone roll the dice see what
comes up I think just a lot of people
don't think like they probably Panic or
freeze up and they just don't think of
you go straight Kamikaze you got nothing
to lose he's gonna kill you
you have a better chance rolling that
car a lot a lot better chance
we're just running into a tree
you know that's probably what I would do
yeah I'd roll it I'd roll the car but if
you're a girl you don't know how to roll
a car if I could just run it right into
a tree well and I kind of feel like if
you run into a tree you might get you
get the airbag and you might like not
get as [__] up as if you rolled it
yeah well no I'd want to [__] everybody
up everyone I want everybody with a
bunch of yeah but if some douche is in
the back seat like saying they got us
well he didn't have an airbag
not in my car he doesn't
you know what I mean yep he's got a
front seat to hit
I'm kind of hoping that he won't have
like a maybe he'll go through the
windshield
take it from an expert roll the [__]
car all right get everybody busted up in
the car bust everybody up Ben said you
need to sideswipe something to take out
the side with the kidnappers on yeah
that might work but that's kind of it
all right
I'd [__] roll the car
yes yes
established that that's the best way all
right and do it in traffic
so everyone sees it
yeah I mean you want if you want as much
attention as possible Right
I mean because he'd be really stupid to
like do anything like that like in front
of everybody speaking of which when I
was
driving to work this morning
I saw there was a rat it I thought it
was a wreck but then when I got around
the corner
it was
a it looked like a single vehicle
accident it was a work van
and it was like kind of on its side like
that and like the passenger side was
like off like the door was open all the
[__] was hanging out of it and it's like
it was all [__] up and I'm sitting
there looking at it going how the [__]
did that happen it almost looked like a
like it blew up hmm like a bomb hit it
or something I didn't see another car
I was just kind of like what how the
[__] did that happen I couldn't see like
what had hit it or what I don't know I
couldn't figure it out but I mean I
didn't have a huge amount of time to
look at it but I was like that's the
weirdest looking [__] accident Lane's
telling you rolling the car is safer
exactly get the car up on the hood
and if you have a [__] seat belt on
and he doesn't you got a big advantage
we'll see I always wear my seatbel
TS I always always
um okay so where was I see so we're
obviously we're almost done yep what's
up
which is good because it's like nine
o'clock and I'm getting really tired but
uh but yeah so
so he got arrested like after this
little girl got away
so both him and Monique got uh arrested
and interrogated
um but they really wouldn't kind of like
uh admit to anything at least at first
now later on
like about a year later Monique actually
uh cracked and told the cops that uh
Michelle had killed a bunch of people
since 1987. so Michelle actually
confessed to killing eight women
um aged between 12 and 30 years old and
he also said he killed a man but they
don't know who it is like he didn't know
who it is and they haven't figured out
like they haven't matched up any case
with that so I mean there's no reason to
doubt it
um because he's they found all the other
people he killed pretty much so uh he
said yeah I killed a dude too but I
don't like no I don't know who it was so
they don't know who it was
um so they actually have found
um
four of the
victims like the bodies they found those
in France and Belgium between 1988 and
2002. now Monique got arrested also
because you know she was apparently an
accomplice and they both got extradited
to France and they actually ended up
helping the police find the bodies of
three of the four missing victims like
over the next two years
so they had a trial in 2008 Michelle was
found guilty of the murders of all seven
of the victims whose bodies had been
recovered
um he was sentenced to life in prison
without the possibility of parole
uh Monique was also sentenced to life
with no possibility of parole for 28
years they were also ordered to pay 1.5
million euros to family members of the
victims neither one of them appealed
their sentences
Michelle actually admitted to eight
murders uh prior to the trial in 2008 so
you know he was just sentenced to seven
of them because one of the bodies was
not found
in February of 2018
uh Michelle confessed to killing two
more women
uh Marie angel domace I think is how you
pronounce her last name who is 18 years
old uh and was disabled uh that was in
July 1988 that he said he did that and
Joanna Parrish who was 20 years old and
she was actually British she was a
student that was studying in France and
uh he apparently killed her in May 1990.
so in November of 2018 so just a couple
years ago uh these two chuckle [__]
were convicted of the murder of farida
Hamish that was the wife of the gang
member that you know they went and
killed and they took all the money
that was uh the last that was the eighth
women woman that he had confessed to
killing
um thank you very much Jeffy art
congrats on the new job Jenny can't be
easy to work with a long commute and
provide us with great content well thank
you very much thanks thank you very much
she's got a couple ways she can go where
it'll work out yeah we're gonna it's
like I said everything's just kind of up
in the air at the moment right we're
kind of like moving things around she's
in demand she's getting a lot of offers
yeah we're seeing a house
we're seeing how it goes yeah
but yeah so because he was convicted of
that eighth murder
um he was given a second life sentence
and then Monique got another 20 years uh
in prison
and then in March of 2020 Michelle comes
out and says oh by the way I killed
somebody else as well I'm like Jesus
Christ it's never going to end
um he said that he killed another woman
named Estelle muzan who had disappeared
uh in 2003.
unfortunately this [__] face is dead he
died uh May 10 2021 he was 79 years old
he died of respiratory failure Monique
Olivier is still alive however uh and is
still serving that life sentence
uh for her you know admitted role in
some of the killings but uh they're kind
of I was just reading an article that
was published a couple months ago where
they were talking about
um they might put Monique on trial like
again because of the four disappearances
like between 1980 and 2003 because she's
basically like the only defendant left
because now Michelle is dead and they
can't like get him for any more stuff so
they might actually put her on trial for
more things like foreclosure and stuff
but I don't really know because some of
the cases were still unresolved and you
know they haven't found bodies and
things like that so so she's still kind
of on the hook for all that [__] even
though he [__] died but like I said
he was I mean he was older he was 79 but
you know it's it's sad that he probably
didn't suffer as much as he made other
people suffer but yeah it's it's not
Justice for these [__] too it
never is really I mean it's it's kind of
shitty like because you would think of
of all the people that
deserve like because I you know most
people I don't think like deserve
anything like really bad to happen to
him but like people like this yeah I
mean yeah I go Old Testament on the
[__] yeah you're talking about
if you're doing that to other people you
if that extreme [__] like that then that
needs to be done to you man if I could
just say it okay I'm not into this sick
and moral High Ground stuff oh well we
would never do that no just call me I'll
take care of it [__] no dudes like
that just can't you just can't let that
[__] go I mean that's just my opinion I
mean particularly in cases like this
like I said I'm usually children and
[__] he's doing this right like I said
it depends on the crimes I'm not real
things like I always do they were a bank
robber or dudes like get out in a bar or
something like yeah
I'm not talking about that yeah um we're
talking about these kind of people yeah
these like [__] serial killers
absolutely no going way out of their way
to hurt [__] people who [__] are
just super innocent underage [__]
girls and I don't think and I mean we've
discussed this before but it's like I I
think like to an extent they I don't
they can't be fixed I don't think like
people like that I don't think they can
be fit no they can only be punished you
know yeah and I'm not saying that just
all criminals across the board because
some criminals like you know that aren't
serial killers obviously but have done
things when they were younger and then
they went to prison for a while or or
they you know got out and then they were
normal members of society again but
serial killers I don't really think that
I don't really think you can fix that
that's awesome studies done by some
psychologists I guess they were kind of
like based psychologists they said that
they could detect antisocial behavior in
boys
by Age Two
six percent of them bite fight scratch
attack and steal from other kids yeah
and it's six percent of them and it's
consistent
by age two they're like that their
entire lives those are the ones that end
up in prisons and now some people end up
in prison they're not of that demo right
so it's not quite the same thing but the
ones that they do these studies can
identify by age two no that's them right
there
that's that
now they're not all as bad as one
another
you know what I mean but chances are
those are your convicts right there you
know
so it makes you wonder if you have the
[__]
ability ability to to detect them by Age
Two
should you go ahead and [__]
Prime crime prevention and do like very
late term abortion
recycle them [__]
or are you gonna say well there's a rate
of error
right that's the thing it's like that's
where you get shitty and like we might
talk about this a little bit when we
talk about Gattaca too because this kind
of goes into that a little bit as well
like genetic determinism yeah is what
you're talking about pretty much because
you know and I'm not denying that it's
like a lot of times you know we've
talked about tons of serial killers on
this show where it's like yeah they were
[__] up like from kids they were
torturing animals and [__] like that
yeah but a lot of them weren't yeah too
and the thing about it also is that
sometimes some kids like that because I
knew some kids that were
pretty [__] up like as kids but they
turned out they grew up and they turned
out normal so it's like you don't ever
know like how that person's gonna do it
and I think most people
99.99 of humans obviously like happily
wouldn't would not kill a two-year-old
kid like no matter how [__] brother
you have to be a very special kind of
person to do that okay
a very Psychopathic yeah well you might
be able to get robots to do it all right
you've been living with a high-tech
Society now but like I said you can't
person that you're telling the future
and you can't tell the future the person
that was discussed the people that were
discussing this case is didn't talk
along those lines pretty much but what
they said was as if there was a way to
contain that six percent
at around age two or three to keep them
so they didn't have interaction with the
mainstream of society crime would be
reduced by about 80 percent
because that's them
all right yeah I mean if you're in a
totalitarian Society like some out of
North Korea you do what must be done do
what must be done Lord Vader and you
[__] take you take those out then you
would have it'd be like the uh it would
be like natural selection okay to where
you're now animal breeding
which having a background in farms and
breeding of horses and then thoroughbred
horses and stuff Eugenics that's what
you're talking about
that's them if you reduce that you could
sterilize them do something else with
them make them some kind of worker
that's the same as killing them because
they're not putting their genes back
into the gene pool generation later you
won't have that problem
that in this there has been certain
States you know and Appalachia and [__]
back in the 20s when they were doing 30s
when they were doing the Eugenics
movement
crime got a lot better when they started
sterilizing all them Hillbillies
because they they weren't inbreeding
anymore and they weren't
[__] fighting and killing people and
you know it does work
it's is it cold yeah it's cold but it's
effective It's very effective it's just
like with any other animal
um
now you see are humans animals yeah
humans are animals they they better be
because you don't want them to be
machines
because that's even worse if you ask me
you don't want Ai and robots and all
that kind of [__] you just improve
humans it'd be a lot better
I agree with [__] Frank Hubert
and [__] Dune and [__] [__] it you
know
just improve the humans and things will
be a lot better
just have to find a humane way of doing
it
you need a good system
now would it would it be constitutional
as far as the American no
no I wouldn't
but we're just talking you know we're
just talking
you're just talking oh yeah yeah I'm
considering it you know just considering
what what their own fake ramifications
would be be better like with Gattaca
is that you just genetically engineer
the kids
to where
they're intelligent and they're not like
that
or are you uh prevent
you prevent certain kinds of people from
being able to have children
get them out of the gene pool and that
would prevent a lot of it
you need some of it but you don't need
that much of it
Ben said when they drained uh eduardus
eduardus Park Lake up the road for me a
few years ago they found a couple of
hundred cars were there people in them
probably the people throwing cars away I
mean I would imagine yeah but it's like
you would think that at least one of
those would have a body yeah I've seen
psycho I know what happens
uh Ben says I have to head out thanks
for the stream have a happy valentine
thank you very much and thank you very
much yeah we're gonna do it we'll do
another show before Valentine's Day but
this was like the big main show before
Valentine's Day because I think
when is Valentine's Day Tuesday right
let me go look on the calendar I think
it's Tuesday
because I was looking and I was just
like oh [__] this is the last main show
before Valentine's Day so maybe we
should do like another killer couples
episode even though we've done a bunch
of those but they're always kind of like
fun to do yeah today is the eighth
Valentine's Day is the 14th well I know
it's the 14th yes so that is that's a
Tuesday that's Tuesday next Tuesday okay
that's when it is
ah all right so
we've been going almost two hours yeah
okay that's a good show so I know I feel
bad because Jen Dubois I'm here late hi
I missed it
Yeah we actually started late because uh
yeah I didn't actually go home until six
and then so we started at like 7 30 and
I said well I'm kind of tired so we're
not trying to try and not go too long
but we went almost two hours which is
pretty good but uh yeah so sorry you got
here late but I gotta go
are you hungry at all no okay all right
because I I eat one week all right shut
that [__] down Jenny all right so we
will be back on Friday night uh doing
our Sidetrack show I guess
um yeah but it will probably be later in
the night again like it'll probably will
probably start at about seven or seven
thirty depending on whatever time I get
home but we're still gonna do one so
that should be like really fun uh
Michael said you got a job I'm sorry
yeah
yep yep yep running out of money so I
had to get uh I had to get a full-time
job so yeah
so that's that's why all the shows are
getting pushed back and we're not
putting up as much stuff and stuff like
that because I just don't have as much
time to do it but we'll uh we'll see how
everything
shakes out we're we're gonna find out
how it goes all right so uh thank you
everybody for driving by thank you for
all these super chats this evening
remember to like and share and comment
uh really helps with the algorithm and
we will see you guys again on Friday
night good night